Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Los músculos y las articulaciones
se mueven y se empujan.
El latido del corazón se acelera.
La sangre ruge
por las arterias y las venas.
Durante el transcurso de un embarazo,
todos los órganos del cuerpo cambian.
Iniciados por una variedad de hormonas,
estos cambios comienzan
tan pronto como inicia el embarazo.
Pocos días después de la fertilización,
el embrión se implanta en el útero.
Como su ADN no coincide
exactamente con el de la madre,
el sistema inmunológico debería
teóricamente reconocerlo como un invasor,
atacarlo y destruirlo, como lo haría
con bacterias u otros microbios dañinos.
Ese es el desafío:
el sistema inmunológico de la madre
necesita proteger a ella y al feto,
pero no puede actuar como suele hacerlo.
Lo que pasa no es tan simple como
una disminución de la respuesta inmune.
En cambio, hay una interacción compleja
que estamos empezando a entender
y que involucra muchos tipos diferentes
de células inmunes
algunas de las cuales parecen proteger al
feto del ataque de otras células inmunes.
El cuerpo también crea en el cuello
uterino un tapón antibacteriano de moco
que mantiene alejados a los gérmenes
y que permanece sellado hasta el parto.
A medida que avanza el embarazo,
el útero se expande hacia arriba y
hacia afuera con el feto en crecimiento.
Para hacer espacio, unas hormonas
llamadas progesterona y relaxina
les indican a los músculos que se aflojen.
Los músculos que impulsan alimentos
y desechos por el tracto digestivo
también se aflojan
lo que los vuelve lentos,
lo que produce estreñimiento
conforme el tracto se ralentiza.
Los músculos relajados
de la parte superior del estómago
pueden hacer que el ácido
salga al esófago y la garganta
causando acidez y reflujo.
Estos cambios pueden empeorar
las náuseas matutinas,
causadas en parte por la hormona HCG
y que también puede ocurrir
en otros momentos del día.
A medida que el útero crece,
empuja el diafragma,
el músculo que se expande y contrae
el pecho con cada respiración.
Esto limita el rango del diafragma.
Para compensar, la hormona progesterona
actúa como estimulante respiratorio,
haciendo respirar a la embarazada
más rápido y así tanto ella como el bebé
pueden obtener suficiente oxígeno
con menor capacidad pulmonar.
Todo esto puede producir en la embarazada
sensación de falta de aire
Entre tanto, los riñones
producen más eritropoyetina,
una hormona que aumenta
la producción de glóbulos rojos.
Los riñones retienen agua y sal adicional
en vez de filtrarlas en la orina
para aumentar el volumen de sangre.
El volumen de sangre de una embarazada
aumenta en un 50 % o más.
Pero también está un poco diluida,
porque solo tiene el 25 %
más de glóbulos rojos.
Por lo general, el cuerpo produce glóbulos
usando hierro de nuestra comida.
Pero durante el embarazo, el feto
también crea su propia sangre
con los nutrientes
de la comida de la madre
quedando menos hierro
y otros nutrientes para la madre.
El corazón tiene que trabajar más
para bombear toda esta sangre
por el cuerpo y la placenta.
La frecuencia cardíaca de
una embarazada aumenta, pero no
entendemos del todo cómo la presión
sanguínea cambia en un embarazo saludable
un área importante de investigación,
porque algunas de
las complicaciones más serias
están relacionadas
con el corazón y la presión arterial.
El útero en expansión
puede presionar las venas:
esto causa acumulación de líquido
en piernas y pies.
Si se presiona una vena grande
llamada vena cava inferior,
esto puede interferir con la sangre
que vuelve al corazón, lo que causa
una caída de la presión arterial luego
de estar de pie por mucho tiempo.
Algunos de estos cambios comienzan
revertir incluso antes del nacimiento.
Poco antes del nacimiento, el feto baja,
disminuyendo la presión sobre el diafragma
y permitiendo que la embarazada
haga respiraciones más profundas.
Durante el trabajo de parto y el parto,
gran parte del exceso de líquido
se pierde cuando se rompe la fuente.
El útero vuelve a encogerse
en las semanas posteriores al nacimiento.
Como al resto del cuerpo,
el embarazo afecta al cerebro,
pero estos efectos son algunos
de los menos entendidos.
Estudios recientes muestran diferencias
en escáneres cerebrales
después del embarazo
y la maternidad temprana,
y sugieren que estos cambios
son adaptaciones.
Eso significa que pueden ayudar
con habilidades maternales,
como una mayor capacidad
para leer señales faciales de los bebés.
La falta de información sobre
los efectos en el cerebro del embarazo
muestra una verdad general: casi todas
las investigaciones sobre el embarazo
se ha centrado en el feto,
en lugar de en las mujeres embarazadas.
Las experiencias del embarazo
varían ampliamente,
tanto en el rango de embarazos saludables
como en las complicaciones de salud;
nuevas investigaciones nos ayudarán
a comprender por qué,
y a desarrollar tratamientos efectivos
cuando sea necesario.
Mientras tanto,
cada embarazo es diferente,
y es importante consultar a un médico
cualquier pregunta específica.
Hoy, damos vuelta
en una esquina emocionante,
a medida que se dedica más investigación
a la asombrosa biología del embarazo.